[Musik]
ja so geht es bestimmt einige unserer
studieren da habe ich mir gedacht
der raum in die cafeteria in die mensa
verschafft eine ganz gute pause und kann
eigentlich auch sehr gut als land
genutzt werden da habe ich mir überlegt
wie macht man das eigentlich und ich
möchte heute immer im vortrag
fremdsprachenunterricht im digitalen
lernen warum internationalisierung zu
hause so eine kleine zusammenstellung
von best practice beispielen zeigen
das ganze ist und offline möglich steht
aber jetzt baut im hintergrund der krone
erfahrung in serie unter dem thema der
digitalisierung und dann musste ich
zuerst kurz eine kleine theoretische
einführung machen begriffe ansprechen
orte des lernens lebens und erlebens was
eigentlich in tag ist für die
fremdsprachen dozenten sehr von
interesse warum ich der meinung wenn das
der digitale lernen raums es sinnvoll
genutzt werden kann auch gerade in
diesem fachbereich und dann wie gesagt
einige beispiele orte des landes ein
lehr ort lernort leer und lernort das
ist für mich der ort und themen methoden
gezielt eingesetzt werden können um den
lernenden einen kompetenz arbeit zu
ermöglichen
auch relevante vierte lebensort unter
lebensort fest ich den ort an dem
alltagskultur beobachtet werden kann
und erlebt werden kann was besonders
wichtig ist für die fachbereiche der
interkulturelle kommunikation und
landeskunde und dann verwende ich noch
den begriff erlebnisort der bringt das
also zusammen dass es ein ort an dem
etwas gelebt wird und an dem dieses
erleben zu einem erlernen führt also zu
verändern von verhalten und zur anhalten
von kompetenzen der intake ist ja nach
krassen definiert als entschuldigung das
war nicht ganz sinnvoll animiert als der
teil des inputs der zuletzt in put ist
im grunde der ganze sprachliche kontext
der lernen in den fremdsprachen
unterricht zur verfügung gestellt wird
input ist der teil der tatsächlich zu
lernen führt also von lernenden auch
aufgenommen verarbeitet wird und erlernt
wird
aufgabe für die fremdsprachen dozenten
ist somit sinnvolles material zu suchen
und bereitzustellen so dass intake
stattfinden kann
und dafür muss eben ein linguistisches
und kulturelles umfeld geschaffen werden
in dem lande die möglichkeit haben sich
zu orientieren und genau das auch zu
nehmen was sie auf ihrem lernweg und in
ihrem höchst individuellen lernprozess
gerade benötigen und verarbeiten können
der digita den lernraum oder im
allgemeinen alle digitalen medien und
möglichkeiten die wir jetzt verwenden
können in der fremdsprache lehre hat vor
und nachteile als einen deutlichen
vorteil sehe ich dass eine stärkere
individualisierung möglich ist zum
beispiel durch private rückmeldung in
suhl meinetwegen kann nicht private
nachrichten schicken und kurs teilnehmer
auf ihre fehler aufmerksam machen was im
klassenzimmer einfach nicht geht da
willkommen es immer andere mit wenn ich
jemanden korrigiert im privaten chat
kann ich jemanden vollkommen anonym und
ohne dass es kommilitonen mitbekommen
auch zum beispiel auf fehler aufmerksam
machen sondern wieder eine nicht ganz
sinnvolle animationen ich entschuldige
mich dafür ortszeit ungebunden zu sein
ist natürlich auch für die im sinne der
individualisierung ziel gerecht und
sinnvoll denn viele habe ich
festgestellt wie lernen am nächsten
sonntag früh um halb vier oder montag
nacht um halb zwölf und da haben wir
gerade keine möglichkeit für und
medienkompetenz wird außerdem aufgebaute
die verwendung von all diesen tools die
uns zur verfügung denen es durchaus
sinnvoll und bringt vielen studierenden
neuen möglichkeiten und ich bin außerdem
der meinung dass ich in zb in zoom
verschiedene sozialfragen viel flexibler
handhaben kann als im klassenzimmer
gruppenarbeit zum beispiel ich bin der
meinung das break out sessions viel
schneller eingerichtet sind mit einigen
mausklicks als studierende im raum
verteilt sind
das ganze kann einen motivierten effekt
haben auf die landen und den gilt es
auszunutzen
die nachteile sind eigentlich ja ganz
ähnlicher art diese medienkompetenz muss
nämlich zunächst aufgebaut werden
und ich stelle immer wieder fest junge
studierende sind experten hauptsächlich
bei instagram und twitter und wenn es
darüber hinaus geht dann muss man noch
sehr sehr viel lernen üben und
vermitteln
das nimmt natürlich viel zeit in
anspruch und bei manchen es da auch
nicht unbedingt die offenheit gegeben
all das zu lernen und das anzuwenden
die technische ausstattung muss
vorhanden sein und bei hat das noch
nicht erlebt dass irgendwas mit der
internetverbindung nicht und dass der
computer hängen bleibt ist irgendwas
schiefgeht das passiert im echten leben
auch ich kann mein geldbeutel genauso
verlieren wie mein handy aber ja wenn
man auch digitale methoden um steigt
dann ist es glaube ich am anfang doch
immer so dass ich relativ häufig
passiert das was wie geht man dass man
wie gesagt die technische ausstattung
auch erst für geld anschaffen muss
ablenkung kann auch geschehen es kann
natürlich passieren dass die digitale
form von dem eigentlichen lernen inhalt
ablenkt und was auch passieren kann wenn
man zum beispiel mobile endgeräte für
abstimmungen für für online quiz oder
ähnliche spielereien einsetzt das dann
natürlich doch schnell noch mal bei
whatsapp geguckt wird auch das ist doch
eine neue nachricht inzwischen gekommen
ist kann natürlich
gut ich möchte die theorie zu ende
bringen denn eigentlich will ich ja ein
paar beispiele vorstellen
der erste lernortes bezeichnet denn
jetzt als ort das passt noch nicht
besser zum begriff tandem ist das
digitale tante mir in klammern denn das
ganze gibt es auch online und offline im
digitalen tandem bring ich bikulturelle
tandems zusammen und eine person muss
den fremden kulturellen hintergrund des
tandem partners beschreiben das kann man
kurs intern machen dass man teilnehmer
zusammenführt oder eben auch über das
international office mit
austauschstudierenden ich arbeite in
ansbach mit einer freiwilligenagentur
zusammen die sich für die integration
von bekannten einsetzt
die tandem partner kommunizieren dann
miteinander lernen sich kennen und
stellen ihren eigenen kulturellen
hintergrund vor ort lernen eben dem kind
kulturellen hintergrund der anderen
person kennen und das passiert
eigentlich über den kommunikationskanal
einer präferenz das kann man natürlich
persönlich machen per telefon zum
facetime whatsapp alles ist erlaubt
das ganze muss dann kommentiert
dokumentiert und kommentiert werden und
wird dann in eine aus arbeit und hier
bietet sich an eine digitale hausarbeit
auszumachen eingearbeitet digital des
heben weil am besten
audios videos und auch bilder
eingebettet werden können am bass eher
vorteilhaft ist
kurze beispiele dazu sie sehen es gleich
an der flagge hier hatten wir ein
deutsch philippinisches tandem und die
philippinische tandem partnerin hat dann
deutschland bis regen und zum beispiel
die deutsche nationalhymne die hier wohl
besonders gefallen hat
als audio in ihr lern portfolio
eingebettet
und sie hat auch einige audios und
videos
eingebettet hier sind wir noch ein
auszug aus der ein foto vom nürnberger
christkindlesmarkt eingebettet hat
anhand des lern portfolios kann ich sehr
gut den prozess eben den lernprozess den
landeskundlichen und kulturell landwirt
sie das nachvollziehen und auch mit dem
entsprechenden kriterien raster dann
bewerten als dozent
der zweite land waren bin ich kurz
vorstellen möchte ist eine digitale
galerie die methode können wir beizeiten
als problemorientiertes lernen oder als
projektorientiertes lernen da gibt es ja
verschiedene begriffe
das ganze funktioniert folgendermaßen
ich suche bilder der alltagskultur aus
der ziel kultur teilnehmer suchen sich
dann ein bild aus dass sie persönlich
auf den ersten blick anspricht und sie
erhalten als anweisung eigentlich nur
dass sie ihre eigenen fragen erarbeiten
müssen um die situation die in dem bild
dargestellt ist zu begreifen
sie müssen dann vertreterin in der
zellkultur kontaktieren
das geschieht am besten geleitet ich
bring da immer auch quasi tandems über
unser international office zusammen oder
auch deutsch studieren der von unseren
partner hochschulen im ausland in dem
ziel kultur in china kommunizieren die
dann über die chips in mexiko
kommunizieren sie über whatsapp das sind
meine
dagegen bei spielen anschließend werden
dann die ergebnisse präsentiert das
heißt das bild das man sich ausgesucht
hat wird erklärt und beschrieben und
situativen kontext dazu erklärt wie man
es eben von dem muttersprachlern aus der
ziel kultur auch erklärt bekommen hat
diese erklärung für die anderen
kursteilnehmer kann wiederum live
geschehen im klassenzimmer kann aber
auch als video aufbereitet und zum
beispiel der lern management system zur
verfügung gestellt werden
weil der abgebildete ist flexibel ich
zeig mal zwei bilder die immer sehr gut
funktionieren und zwar campusleben in
china ich glaube jeder stellt sich jetzt
die frage was machen die denn da mit
ihren riesen flaschen sind das
thermosflaschen und das scheint ja im
sommer aufgenommen zu sein weil alle
kurz endlich zum brennen warum stellt
man da hunderttausend thermosflaschen
vor dem gebäude ab was ist das was soll
das ist sehr spannend dann raus zu
finden oder zu sehen wie die post
teilnehmer aus von wasser eigentlich
passiert und warum das passiert
und aus mexiko war das eben im
spanischunterricht auch immer ganz gut
funktioniert ja mit diesem bild ein bild
vom die albatrosse in mexiko wo dann
natürlich auch die fragen ganz gut
antizipiert antizipiert werden können
nämlich warum so viele von diesen blumen
ist dass eine bestimmte blume was es mit
den totenköpfen was hat es eigentlich
mit diesen ganzen alltag ähnlichen mit
dieser aufmachung auf sich was bedeutet
das was wird da eigentlich gefeiert
der dritte digitalen raum sind soziale
netzwerke ganz einfach das habe ich mir
natürlich nicht selbst überlegt sondern
das wurde schon vor vielen vier jahren
erfunden
apps wie hello tandem whatsapp oder wie
z für einen ganz leichten fremdsprachen
unterricht eingebunden werden wenn ich
eine persönliche kommunikation zwischen
inliner der zielsprache und einem
muttersprachler betreue und mögliche und
diese kommunikation dann dokumentiert
wird und zum beispiel anhand eines
bildschirm abdrucks von einer whatsapp
von whatsapp nachrichtenaustausch für
die deck dokumentation auch in einem
land portfolio oder in einer
schriftlichen hausarbeit gefordert wird
das ganze kann dann so aussehen als
chinesisch unterricht ist es natürlich
von besonderer bedeutung dass die kurs
teilnehmer auch lernen chinesische
zeichen am handy zu verwenden und
darzustellen das es mit einem
nebeneffekt
und das gilt auch für russisch wie wir
hier auf der rechten seite sehen ganz
toll auch diese erbfälle talk ist das da
kann man sich gegenseitig korrigieren
das heißt ich schreibe hier oben eine
nachricht und man lernt an dem sieg mir
dann die korrigierte fassung zurück und
das ganz toll rot markiert was ich
falsch geschrieben habe und wie es
eigentlich richtig gewesen wäre
hilft mir also als fremdsprachen lernen
und das kann ich dann in meinem land
portfolio dokumentieren und zeigen wie
ups gelangt was hab ich gedacht
der vierte lernraum ist der campus und
da hat es in den letzten semestern
einige male ein video tanja durchgeführt
und kurze hosen vorstellung des videos
angefertigt und zwar in der fremdsprache
das geht mit ganz einfache ausstattung
oder auch mit etwas anspruchsvollere
ausstattung werden wir gleich sehen
das sind 3 bis 5 minütige vorstellung
des videos des eigenen campus der
eigenen hochschule und die werden dann
an eine partnerhochschule geschickt die
anschließend ein ähnliches video
erstellt und das eben auf englisch oder
deutsch je nachdem welche sparten dort
angeboten werden zurückgeschickt
also quasi wie früher eine
brieffreundschaft kann man hier eine
video freundschaft initiieren die auf
hochschulebene und dann natürlich auch
auf der individuellen ebene gepflegt
werden kann
kürze beispiele dazu ein sehr schön
aufbereitet das video aus dem chinesisch
kurs seit zwei jahren geschenkt
ansbach dpa bei turnieren der liga
niemand kann kann titan zum gau
und das schöne ist dass also aus der
zellkultur von der partnerhochschule ein
antwort video kommt dass auch ein
gewisser weise bezug auf die inhalte
nimmt des ursprünglichen videos und auch
eben lebensorte aus der ziel kultur
vorstellt hier sehen wir eine szene aus
china vierte hinter englisch angaben
unter anderem schwerkraft je nachdem wie
gut oder verbesserungsbedürftig die
sprachkenntnisse sind kann man dann
natürlich die videos auch mit
untertiteln versehen oder nicht ein
kurzes beispiel noch wo wir sehen das
ein sehr enger inhaltliche bezug in
diesen videos hergestellt werden kann
und es wirklich eine ganz direkte
kommunikation zwischen den sprachkursen
oder zwischen den hochschulen geschaffen
werden kann
hier lässt so gegebene maßen der ton
sehr zu wünschen übrig wir sehen aber
gleich es ging ja und diese statue und
hier kommt das antwort video aus spanien
wären eine komische stimmt zu aber wer
wie er wissen müssen bedeutet und das
ist dann für die kosten immer ein
spanischkurs und ansbach sondern
besonderes erlebnis wenn sie die antwort
aus spanien sehen mit diesen
sprachlichen bezug wir haben auch eine
komische struktur damit also mit direkte
kommunikation hergestellt die denke ich
ein sprachliches ein kulturelles lernen
ermöglicht ganz kurz zum schluss gehe
ich noch auf die nutzung einer
lernplattform
ja als digitalen lernen raum ein und
zwar dass fehler wie kann im unterricht
folgendermaßen genutzt werden
das andere ist um eine fehler sammlung
in die sich jeder selbst eintragen kann
und zwar auf öffentliche aber natürlich
auch anonyme weise man kann dort seine
eigenen häufigen fehler eintragung und
kann natürlich auch fehler eintragen die
man bei kommilitonen beobachtet
natürlich anonym
diese fehler werden dann als fehler
auflistung im lern management system in
diesem weg geben veröffentlicht und vor
allem strukturiert also klassifiziert
oder kategorisiert und sie können auch
bewertet werden das heißt gewichtet und
zwar durch die lernenden selbst weil es
im laufe des semesters herausstellt
welche fehler machen wir eigentlich
immer wieder das heißt welches und
hochfrequente fehler an denen wir noch
arbeiten können und wollen hoffentlich
und damit wird aufrecht autonome weiße
di di di di meter kognitive ebene auch
schritten auf der lernende dann heben
sich selbst zum ziel nehmen wie sie ihre
eigenen fehler erkennen analysieren
verbessern und aus ihnen lernen
so kann ein fehler wiki im modell
aussehen und das lässt sich natürlich in
alle gängigen lernen management systeme
einbinden
zugegebenermaßen ein von mir erstelltes
raste als vorbild sieht nicht immer so
strukturiert aus wenn alle studierenden
sich einbringen können in dieses metier
und teilweise dann bei der formatierung
der einzelnen zeiten sagen wir mal
layout und design test ist noch etwas
unterstützung brauchen aber in der regel
immer getan ist es so dass meine akkus
teilnehmer immer aus allen fachbereichen
kommen
jetzt ist was immer jemand auch
multimedia und kommunikation oder
ähnlichen studiengängen arbeite das dann
gerne übernimmt und sagt ich kann mich
mal ins layout und vielleicht fällt sich
die person dann auch inhaltlich zurück
das ist in ordnung ich bin der meinung
dass sie trotzdem was dabei lernen
können
kurz zum abschluss noch empfehlungen die
genannten methoden sollten natürlich
zielgerichtet angewendet werden und
nicht nur zur abwechslung also die form
sollte sich tatsächlich nach dem inhalt
rechten was möchte ich vermitteln welche
aktivität ist da für sinnvoll
ganz wichtig ist es den rahmen genau
abzustecken wird das im unterricht oder
außerhalb des unterrichts gemacht ist
das teil der leistungserhöhung gibt es
dafür punkte da gibt es die
unterschiedlichsten konstellationen je
nach kurs inhalt und ein ziel das muss
man sich eben vorher überlegen und dann
ganz wichtig transparent kommunizieren
und von anfang an eben klare
anforderungen geben und klar machen was
bewertet wird wenn diese aktivitäten
bewerten werden realistische planung das
ist natürlich bei den videos immer
wieder mal schief gegangen
einige der videos haben wir tatsächlich
innerhalb von drei stunden aus in einer
vierstündigen am unterrichtseinheit
drehen können wenn die etwas schöner
werden sollen dann verplant man sich da
ordentlich und braucht natürlich viel
mehr zeit die bessere ausrüstung und
auch personen mit der entsprechenden
kommen betrieb
und dann mein tipp einfach bitte
ausprobieren bloß keine angst haben denn
man kann jederzeit jeden um hilfe bitten
ich frage auch ganz auf meine studenten
jetzt funktioniert das gerade nicht hat
jemand ne und jeder kennt irgend eine
app oder irgendeine seite im internet
oder irgendwas was ich noch nicht
kennengelernt habe und was mir in der
situation weiter hilft und wie gesagt
sind alle diese aktivitäten online und
offline möglich da muss man sich eben
auch überlegen wie kann ich am besten
meine lehre einbinden und zielgerecht
aufbereiten
und das für die tiere haben sich meine
schauspieler mit sicherheit mit
sicherheit immer wieder positiv in
erinnerung rufen können
ich glaube diese videodreh ist wirklich
hängen geblieben und ich glaube genau
das ist es was ich erreichen will man
ändert sich an das was man im unterricht
gemacht hat und man hat dann was dabei
gelernt denke ich jetzt würde ich zur
diskussion über gehen ich habe die eine
kleine literaturliste auch
zusammengestellt ich danke zur verfügung
stellen aber jetzt bin ich erst gespannt
auf fragen und kommentare